die problemlage fängt ja nicht erst beim
blackout das ist genau das was ich hier
von auch schon gesagt habe die
netzagentur würde unter umständen im
winter das wird doch offen so
kommuniziert gezwungen seien große
abnehmer vorher mit ansage abzunehmen
das ist für die unternehmen nicht so
katastrophal wie ein plötzliches aus des
strom und gaszufuhr aber es ist
natürlich auch für den
wirtschaftsstandort ein extremer schaden
also jetzt war ja gerade in dieser woche
der arbeitgebertag in berlin
es herrscht panik wir hatten vorher
schon in deutschland die höchsten
strompreise europas jetzt sind die
plötzlich
versechsfacht verachtfacht das heißt das
sind richtige existenznöte was jetzt an
hilfen vielleicht nötig sein wird weil
es geht nicht um einzelne branchen es
geht um weite teile unserer industrie